france info et france 24 présente
[Musique]
bonjour la russie montre les dents
pendant que l'europe regarder du côté de
la pologne et la biélorussie moscou
massé des troupes à la frontière
ukrainienne c'est du moins le constat
fait soudain par l'otan et les états
unis faut-il craindre une recrudescence
des combats voire même une invasion
russe comme l'affirment washington dans
sept régions d'ukraine le dombass ou
déjà près de 13000 personnes ont péri
depuis 2014 on va tenter d'y répondre
dans ce nouveau numéro du monde dans
tous ses états votre rendez-vous
géopolitique sur france info et france
24 avec vous tatiana castrés va jean
bonjour vous êtes chercheuse vous
diriger le centre russie et nuit à
l'ifri mais d'abord clergé routes dites
nous donc comment en est on arrivé là et
bien parce que l'ukraine est un pays qui
est coincé entre deux blocs on le voit
très bien sur cette carte détaillée donc
l'ukraine partage une longue frontière
avec la russie si elle est ce qui fait
environ 1500 km et puis à l'est une
autre frontière presque aussi longue de
1300 km avec l'europe donc c'est un
territoire qui est de tout temps sous
tension déjà en 2014 avec la crimée
l'annexion de la crimée ici en grès et
puis ces territoires contestés du nom
basse sur lesquels il ya toujours des
conflits armés actuellement le bilan des
courses est bien c'est que le territoire
a perdu 7% de sa de sa superficie et la
superficie qui est passé d'environ 600
mille kilomètres carrés à
576 km carrés qui a perdu également un
cinquième de sa population depuis
l'indépendance du 24 août 1991 néanmoins
ça reste l'un des pays les plus peuplés
d'europe avec 45 millions d'habitants à
noter que l'ukraine ne fait ni partie de
l'europe ni de l'otan et cette guerre
qui se prolonge à bas bruit aux portes
de l'europe menace de repartir de plus
belle le sujet est si grave que joe
biden et vladimir poutine ont dû
convoquer un échange au sommet par
visioconférence deux heures durant un
épisode digne de la guerre froide que
nous résume antoine casabonne pour
france télévisions
quelques sourires échange d'amabilités
c'est bon de vous revoir en
visioconférence joe biden et vladimir
poutine affiche est un ton léger et
pourtant les changes était tendu deux
heures de pourparlers afin d'éviter un
conflit armé en ukraine résultat selon
un communiqué de la maison blanche joe
biden a fait savoir à vladimir poutine
que la russie s'exposerait à de fortes
sanctions entre autres économique en cas
d' escalade militaire en ukraine
washington et l'otan accuse la russie de
masser des troupes à la frontière
ukrainienne en vue d'envahir le pays à
la manière de l'annexion de la crimée en
2014 selon les services de renseignement
américains quatre-vingt quinze mille
soldats russes se trouve déjà aux portes
de l'ukraine un chiffre qui pourrait
atteindre 175 milles dès l'année
prochaine
le but faire pression sur l'ukraine pour
l'empêcher de rejoindre l'otan durant
l'entretien poutine a demandé des
garanties sur le nom élargissement de
l'alliance occidentale vers l'est au
centre du conflit le gouvernement
ukrainien qui exprime sa vive inquiétude
je ne crois pas que la russie ait
quelque chose à gagner en ukraine car ce
serait un massacre vraiment sanglant et
les ruses rentreront aussi dans des
cercueils
un message fort pour obtenir des
soutiens partout dans le monde à l'issue
de l'entretien joe biden à qui l'on
reproche de faire trop souvent cavalier
seul a téléphoné à ses homologues
européens dont le président emmanuel
macron afin de maintenir un contact
étroit avec ses alliés
des alliés européens étroitement associé
au diapason même un des états unis sur
cette question c'est important qu'ils
parlent d'une même voix face à la russie
tatiana castrés va gens en tout cas
depuis le début depuis 2014 les
occidentaux considèrent que c'est
l'occident dans l'ensemble et la
sécurité du continent européen qui sont
menacés donc ils ont cherché une réponse
commune au début les sanctions ont été
mis en parallèle par les états unis et
par l'union européenne ensuite les
etats-unis ont mis plus de sanction donc
il ya un certain décalage aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'on a mis construction avant
tout une sanctions individuelles ciblées
c'est à dire il y a une liste des
personnes qui sont interdits d'entrée
sur le territoire de l'union européenne
et des états unis est interdit aussi
d'avoir des comptes dans les banques
europe 1 il y a aussi une série de
sanctions financières et économiques par
exemple sur les technologies à usage du
voile ou les technologies qui permettent
le forage on sait que la russie est très
dépendante de la rente énergétique
mais les sanctions ont aussi des limites
au port et oui on va en reparler dans la
suite de cette émission en tout cas près
deux cents mille soldats russes auraient
été regroupés ces derniers temps à la
frontière avec l'ukraine et donc quel
but tatiana golovin rouquette pour
france 24 à moscou et bien rappel il
s'agit avant tout pour la russie de
montrer les muscles chose qu'elle fait
régulièrement en amassant des troupes à
la frontière avec l'ukraine depuis que
le conflit est entré dans une phase
larvée à chaque fois on fait qu'elle a
eu besoin d'appuyer un round de
négociations politiques en brandissant
la menace militaire cette fois la menace
et de la hauteur du message que je veux
envoyer vladimir poutine à l'ukraine et
à l'occident et pour cause il considère
que sa ligne rouge à savoir l'entrée
possible de l'ukraine dans l'otan peut
désormais être franchis à l'heure moscou
ira-t-elle jusqu'à envahir l'ukraine
sont ceux qui considèrent que cette
question est mal posée puisque des
troupes des officiers et des mercenaires
russes ils sont déjà depuis 2014 la
question est surtout de savoir si
vladimir poutine mènerait une attaque
ouvertement en ukraine alors que depuis
le début la russie mène une guerre
hybride et cache son rôle dans tous les
cas ici à moscou tous les analystes
s'accordent à dire que vladimir poutine
n'aurait pas intérêt à faire cela du
fait des sanctions encore plus dur et de
l'isolément encore plus fort auquel il
exposerait son pays dans tous les cas le
bruit de bottes à la frontière
ukrainienne a eu au moins pour effet
escompté par vladimir poutine d'amener
l'otan et les états unis à considérer la
position de moscou est probable que tant
que ces négociations auront lieu est
bien la russie ne se décidera pas
envahir être directement et ouvertement
l'ukraine vous non plus tatiana 80
agents vous ne croyez pas aux risques
d'invasion de l'ukraine par la russie
je ne crois pas d'une part jusqu'à
présent avec ce qu'on a vu avec la
miction de la crimée la guerre à l'est
de l'ukraine on a vu plus tôt la russie
procéder par surprise stratégique et pas
avec les annonces de tambours ou donne
quasiment la date de l'invasion on parle
aujourd'hui de fin janvier quand les
routes gelées vont permettre aux chars
d'avancer j'essaie de réfléchir aux
risques et aux opportunités
les risques sont énormes il y à de
nouvelles sanctions forcément qui seront
annoncés le nord stream 2 le gazoduc qui
relie la russie à l'allemagne va se
retrouver à nouveau en péril alors que
la russie a eu beaucoup de difficultés à
obtenir la fin de sa construction et
ensuite on peut imaginer les différents
scénarios par exemple la déconnexion du
swift qu'il y a quelques années dmitri
mededev ancien président russe avait dit
que ce serait considérée comme une
déclaration de guerre à la russie donc
les risques sont énormes par ailleurs
les partis qui sont séparatiste de fait
sont déjà extrêmement lié à la russie il
y a les passeports russes qui ont été
distribués les entreprises ont l'accès
au marché russe etc allaient envahir la
partie qui sous le contrôle des heures
de thé centrale de kiev c'est une autre
paire de manches là on est dans une
ce serait dans un cas d'occupation qui à
mon avis ne serait pas réaliste et
durable ce que veut un semble-t-il le
kremlin l'assurance que l'ukraine ne
rejoigne jamais l'otan peut-il les
obtenir ces garanties vladimir poutine
c'est extrêmement difficile il ya
vraiment deux concepts là qui se
contredisent d'une part dans la charte
de paris il est marqué que chaque pays
souverain a le droit de choisir ses
alliances et la façon dont il va assurer
sa sécurité c'est exactement ce qu dit
l'ukraine est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que l'ukraine a aujourd'hui dans sa
constitution un amendement qui a été
validé et qui dit que la russie ville à
l'ukraine par don vise la vision à
l'otan et à l'union européenne d'autre
part vous avez la russie qui dit non
l'adhésion aux alliances des voisins qui
se sentent maintenant c'est dans ce cas
là c'est quelque chose qui est
impossible et donc depuis les l'arrivée
de vladimir poutine au pouvoir en vérité
même avant même si en chine en vérité
ces loups pointent la russie ne souhait
pas l'élargissement de l'otan envers ses
frontières et les ch'ti même que l'otan
en tant qu'alliance militaire au rite
disparaître en même temps que le pacte
de varsovie et donc je pense que l'a dit
martine cherche quand héritage politique
à par l'injection de la crimée dole et
c'est aussi cette garantie de non
élargissement de l'otan et de non
installation des équipements militaires
à ses frontières en parallèle l'otan ne
sont pas prêcher un de donner une date à
volodimir zelensky le président
ukrainien qui à plusieurs reprises cette
année a souhaité rejoindre le plan
d'action pour l'adhésion c'est l'étape
préalable à l'adhésion en bonne et due
forme allen en s'attelant il y a eu une
promesse de principe en quelque sorte
qui a été donnée à au sommet de l'otan à
bucarest en 2008 que l'otan mais que
l'ukraine mais aussi la géorgie à les
rejoindre le temps ça se fait depuis
quatre mois plus tard pas la guerre
éclair de la russie en géorgie d'août
tout à fait absolument donc il n'y a pas
de date précise et entre les alliés de
l'otan il y à aussi certains désaccords
la france et l'allemagne notamment sont
beaucoup plus réticente que d'autres
pays d'accueillir l'ukraine au sein de
l'otan tout en sachant pertinemment
qu'il y aura des soucis avec la russie
derrière l'adhésion à l'otan une
perspective qui semble en tout cas bien
lointaines aux habitants du dombass ceux
qui vivent le la ligne de front non que
la guerre comme perspective depuis sept
ans maintenant le révoquer une invasion
de la russie leur paraît tout aussi
incongru qui côtoie au quotidien des
combattants séparatistes dont un nombre
non négligeable ont la nationalité russe
illustration dans la ville d'albi cas
avec un gulliver craag et elena
volochine pour france 24
lusine à charbon d'avenir cas maintenu
la ville ukrainienne sur la ligne de
front à flot tout au long de la guerre
ici on préfère d'ailleurs ne pas parler
du conflit j'essaie de ne pas regarder
les nouvelles la ville est assez dur
comme ça pourtant le sud de la ville est
dévastée par les combats
l'armée ukrainienne tient ses positions
dont les usines aux ruines
ici les échanges de tirs sont quasi
quotidiens l'ennemi est à moins de 100
mètres pour se tourner si guy ils n'ont
pas de suite dans les idées il peut
tirer n'importe quoi n'importe quand
mais prostrée pour cet officier la
question d'une invasion de l'ukraine par
la russie est caduque
lorsqu'on capture un prisonnier de
guerre et qu'il un passeport russe
pourtant ces soldats ne s'attendent pas
à une escalade majeure
il dit sans arrêt qu'il va y avoir une
attaque que les russes hamas leur force
c'est pour ça que je n'y crois pas il
subirait de trop grosses terre
voilà ce qui se passe sur le terrain
tatiana caste ou évasion l inverse un
vladimir poutine a plusieurs fois mis en
garde en cas de retour de la frontière
orientale sous le contrôle de kiev un
massacre serait possible des
séparatistes pro-russes par le pouvoir
ukrainien ce danger il existe d'après
vous c'est un discours qui a qu'on a
vraiment beaucoup entendu en 2014 et
2015 c'est un discours qui a précédé et
l'annexion de la crimée et ce qui s'est
passé à l'est de l'ukraine et la
propagande russe y met énormément
l'accent ce que je vois en ukraine pour
y aller régulièrement c'est que les gens
souhaitent avant tout de la paix quand
vous pensez à l'élection de vladimir
solide ce qui il a été élu avec un
discours de la paix et pas de la guerre
il a promis d'amener la paix dans notre
base c'est une autre paire de manches
qu'il n'y arrive toujours pas et c'est
vrai qu'il ya eu aussi des incidents
comme l' incendie
à la maison des syndicats au dessin et
l' enquête sur cette affaire en avant
sur toujours pas mais je ne crois pas un
instant au massacre que l'armée
ukrainienne pourrait organiser en
revanche le discours sur la défense du
territoire ne siens national de la
souveraineté de l'intégrité territoriale
il est extrêmement fort ressentiment
nationaliste hindou crâne il est fort
aussi le sentiment national pardon et
depuis bientôt huit ans maintenant avec
la guerre qui déchire le cren certains
prennent le parti d'en rire c'est le cas
du chanteur et réalisateur série phare
fois sa vidéo bandeira réalisé lors de
l'annexion de la crimée a déjà recueilli
près de 4 millions de vues voyez
[Musique]
sly kazim majid et baudin
c'est déjà la fin de la première partie
du monde dans tous ses états on se
retrouve dans un instant juste après un
journal sur france 24
france info et france 24 présente
[Musique]
suite du monde dans tous ses états on
continue à analyser la crise aux portes
de l'europe en ukraine avec vous tatiana
casse tout et va jean chercheuse
directrice du centre russie nei à l'ifri
si l'ukraine fait tant trembler l'europe
c'est bien sûr parce que l'adversaire
n'est autre que la russie puissance
redoutable et redouté mais aussi claire
giraut car l'ukraine est le lieu où
transite le gaz russe oui le gaz est
clairement au coeur des tensions il
s'agit d'un gaz russe qui va donc
alimenter l'europe et qui va transiter
par l'ukraine pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée en proportion c'est donc un
cinquième du gaz destiné à l'europe qui
transitent par l'ukraine ce qui
représente évidemment une grosse
quantité d'argent pour l'ukraine c'est
ce que l'on appelle le droit de péage
depuis 1991 depuis l'indépendance c'est
en permanence un sujet de conflit et
bien sûr avec l'annexion de la crimée
les choses ne se sont pas arrangées
nouveau revers aujourd'hui avec donc la
construction d'un pipeline
c'est un pipeline qui a été construit
donc en mer baltique et donc il va
permettre de relier directement la
russie à l'allemagne est donc ce sera un
manque à gagner important pour l'ukraine
qui devrait perdre près d'un million 1
milliard d'euros l'ukraine tatiana
castrés va j'en vis dans la dépendance
au gaz russe à travers ce droit de péage
c'est quelque chose qui est important et
le droit de nous les experts encore plus
tôt des droits de transit en effet avant
la conclusion du dernier accord qui a
été prolongée de cinq ans sur le transit
le cren gagner à peu près 3 milliards de
dollars par an avec ce droit de transit
aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu moins le
président céline ce qui a dit que ces 7
milliards de dollars que l'ukraine
allait gagner enfin quand donc la durée
de son nouveau contrat c'est donc
quelque chose qui est important pour
l'économie ukrainienne
qui c'est une économie endettés qui a
ses fragilités qui a aussi quelques
atouts mais néanmoins les ukrainiens ne
voudrais pas perdre en effet cette
source de revenus au point où lors de la
crise énergétique récente ils ont
proposé 50 % de remise sur les droits de
transit à la russie que la russie n'a
pas pris le rennes dépendante du gaz
russe l'europe aussi évidemment puisque
c'est le client final des pays comme
l'allemagne ont même intérêt d'après
vous à négocier directement avec la
russie en cherchant des voies de
contournement du territoire ukrainien
comme ce gazoduc nord stream 2 ce qu'il
faut comprendre en fait c'est quand on
parle de la construction du gazoduc nord
stream 2 il ne s'agit pas d'augmenter
les volumes du gaz qui est livré à
l'europe mais il s'agit de diversifier
les voies depuis plusieurs années la
russie cherche à se débarrasser de ce
transit via l'ukraine qu'elle estime
être un partenaire au début instable
aujourd'hui simplement hostile et donc
ils ne souhaitent plus payer le crème
pour cela et c'est pour ça que le nord
stream 1 a été construit et le nord
stream ii est quasiment finie mais pas
encore certifiées et qui doit porter à
110,1 milliards de mètres cubes le
volume total qui sera livrée donc par
ces ce gazoduc si la deuxième tranche le
deuxième tracé est mis en ligne un
projet que se dit prêt à remettre en
cause le nouveau gouvernement allemand
dow jones l'allemagne peut-elle y
renoncer ça aurait quelles conséquences
pour berlin je dirais que l'allemagne
depuis le début a une position très
intéressante voire ambiguë sur le sujet
et angela merkel a dit à plusieurs
reprises que c'est un projet privé
purement économique or on voit très bien
que c'est un projet qui a une portée
politique et géopolitique
l'allemagne a été finalement très
cohérente jusqu'au bout anguila merkel a
défendu ce projet est le deuxième tracé
foule dire c'est déjà après l'annexion
de la crimée que ça a été discuté avec
les russes probablement dans la tête des
allemands c'est un moyen de rattacher la
russie à l'europe de renforcer les liens
de la stabiliser aussi via sur ce moyen
là aujourd'hui je ne vois pas en dépit
du discours évidemment qu'il y ait à la
présence des troupes russes à la
frontière la nouvelle ministre des
affaires étrangères semble mettre en
cause le projet alors qu'ils ont en
réalité avec sa politique énergétique et
climatique
l'allemagne qui ne veut plus de
nucléaire qui ne veut plus de charbon
finalement a besoin du gaz russe est en
vérité depuis 2014 les livraisons du gaz
russe en europe même augmenté on le voit
bien en tout cas derrière la relation
entre la russie et l'ukraine un autre
acteur est omniprésent c'est l'europe
n'est ce pas jean gaspard hutteau vos
quêtes pour france télévisions à
bruxelles ici à bruxelles la situation à
la frontière ukrainienne est jugée
extrêmement préoccupantes les 27 chefs
d'état et de gouvernement ayant
d'ailleurs consacré une grande partie de
leur sommet cette semaine et à l'issue
de leurs discussions bezos mis en garde
vadimir poutine si la russie intervient
en ukraine elle s'exposera à de lourdes
conséquences un avertissement commun de
l'union européenne et de l'otan depuis
le début de cette escalade militaire les
européens font preuve d'unité sur le
sujet et ils privilégient la dissuasion
ils ont donc reconduit les sanctions qui
sont déjà en place depuis sept ans
depuis l'annexion de la crimée et ils
menacent d'en prendre d'autres et en
même temps il continue de poursuivre la
voix diplomatique emmanuel macron à
rencontrer le président ukrainien ici à
bruxelles en compagnie dow jones le
nouveau chancelier allemand et tous
trois se sont mis d'accord pour
reprendre le dialogue avec vladimir
poutine mais qui lui préfère discuter
avec les états unis la situation reste
donc très instable
jusqu'où d'après-vous l'europe est-elle
prête à aller à tatiana castrés va gens
pour défendre l'ukraine face aux
prétentions de la russie on voit y
compris paris un qui commence à rouler
un peu les épaules face à ce risque
russe on a rappelé au début l'ukraine
n'est pas membre ni de l'union
européenne ni deux le temps ils sont
demandeurs mais ils ne sont pas membres
donc on n'ira pas faire la guerre à nuuk
rennes pour défendre l'ukraine au titre
de l'article 5 du traité de l'otan oui à
la solidarité envers l'un des membres
attaqués qui
est considéré comme lé attaques contre
tout le monde on n'en est pas là avec le
cren donc ce qui va se passer c'est ce
qu'on avait vu depuis 2014 finalement de
nouvelles sanctions très probablement
les sanctions individuelles mais
probablement aussi des sanctions
économiques mais avec lesquels l'europe
est extrêmement prudente elle reste le
premier partenaire commercial de la
russie avec quarante deux pour cent des
du volume des échanges commerciaux
et les dépendantes ou en matière
énergétique comme on a vu et le feedback
en fait l'effet de retour sur les
compagnies européennes et les états
européens ppe est aussi extrêmement fort
donc le but est de marquer le coup mais
sans se faire mal non plus quelles sont
les perspectives aujourd'hui pour le
cren d'une éventuelle future adhésion à
l'union européenne elle qui a déjà un
accord d'association depuis 2014 avec le
temps il n'ya donc il y a une promesse
mais aucune date d'adhésion les
ukrainiens d'ailleurs demandeurs qu'on
leur ouvre des perspectives bien
évidemment qu fixer une sorte de feuille
de route pour pouvoir est allé les
craintes aujourd'hui de la russie c'est
que même si l'ukraine mais pas
formellement membre de le temps que le
ton quand même renforce suffisamment les
liens pour que l'ukraine devienne comme
on dit une sorte de porte avions au
gagnant pas loin des frontières russes
ça c'est la grande crainte avec l'union
européenne les choses sont beaucoup plus
avancés on ne va pas non plus la date de
l'adhésion mais on a l'accord
d'association on a un régime sans visas
on a un accord de libre échange donc il
ya une feuille de route très clair que
l'ukraine suis sur le chemin des
réformes et en échange et là elles
bénéficient des aides de l'union
européenne ainsi que du fonds monétaire
international avec ces oligarques sa
corruption parfois même le crime
organisé le cren n'était elle pas par
bien des aspects un partenaire à
fréquentable pour l'union européenne est
ce qu'on peut vraiment parler d'un état
de droit y compris au plan jeudi les
iraniens sont les premiers à reconnaître
ces problèmes et ils font ils mettent en
place des institutions et les lois
nécessaires pour le taux clottey contre
les phénomènes là on peut citer
plusieurs exemples notamment une loi
récente antilles où les gars que le
président de la dîmière zelensky un fait
passé et l'a fait certains progrès et il
en a encore plus à faire et l'ukraine le
sait et la société ukrainienne qui est
extrêmement active demande par exemple à
l'occident à tout visiteur occidental
qui passe de faire pression sur le
gouvernement ukrainien pour qu'ils ne
lâchent rien en matière de lutte contre
la corruption
ça reste une blessure en tout cas pour
nombre d'ukrainiens une sidération pour
les peint aussi qui n'en croyait pas
cela dit mirko tine capable rattachement
de la crimée au territoire russe en 2014
a créé une véritable fracture entre
moscou et le reste de l'europe retour
sur ces images c'était à l'occasion des
célébrations du 9 mai date à laquelle
les russes comme aimant la victoire sur
l'allemagne nazie pour l'occasion
vladimir poutine s'était rendu à
sébastopol dans cette crime est tout
juste annexée
devant le port de sébastopol une dizaine
de navires angers comme au garde à vous
la mise en scène à un objectif célébrer
vladimir poutine comme un chef de guerre
victorieux nous célébrons aujourd'hui le
69e anniversaire de la grande guerre
patriotique contre l'ennemi
cette phrase renvoie la résistance de
sébastopol face aux bombardements nazis
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale
mais l'amalgamé est vite fait la crimée
victorieuse en 1945 le serait à nouveau
en 2014 voilà comment vladimir poutine
justifie son rattachement
[Musique]
2014 restera dans l'histoire comme
l'année où les gens qui viennent ici ont
fermement fait le choix de la russie oui
mais ce sont
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
ont assisté à ce discours pour les
russes la crimée fait désormais partie
intégrante de leur pays pour le reste du
monde cette annexion d'un territoire
ukrainien est illégal
quelques heures plus tôt l'homme fort du
kremlin avait présidé le traditionnel
défilé de mode où
onze mille soldats mobilisés pour cette
exaltation du patriotisme
c'est un jour où nous ressentons de
manière très aigu ce que cela signifie
d'être fidèle à sa patrie et combien il
est important de servir ses intérêts
ces démonstrations de force servent la
stratégie de vladimir poutine
montrer au monde la puissance de la
russie hier pour répondre symboliquement
à des manoeuvres de l'otan
le numéro un russe a fait tester des
missiles intercontinentaux
les plus puissants atteint un terrain
vierge au kamtchatka une presqu'île
russe à 8000 km de moscou c'est à dire
que ces missiles pourraient atteindre
les états unis
on vient de voir sur ces images tatyana
kotova jean fut vécue par beaucoup comme
un fait accompli pourtant nombreux de
russin considèrent eux la crimée sous
pavillon ukrainien comme une erreur de
nikita khrouchtchev que vladimir poutine
aurait simplement réparer absolument
c'est tout à fait la perception russe on
ne parle pas d'ailleurs de l'annexion de
la crimée on parle de la réintégration
du retour de la crimée à la mère-patrie
au fond on peut le voir même dans la
littérature russe post soviétique ou
d'un certain film culte on parle de la
crimée comme d'une grande perte et d'une
erreur qui n'aurait jamais dû avoir lieu
donc en effet c'est un sentiment qui est
très présent et par ailleurs en fait la
crimée et est même content élite et
ukrainienne avant 2014
l'influencé russe est extrêmement forte
il y avait une universitaire us
évidemment il y avait la flotte de la
mer noire donc la présence de beaucoup
de marins qui se sont intégrés dans
cette ville a donc la russie n'a jamais
perdu une influence sur cette région là
c'est pour ça que c'est un cap très
unique et la russie a pu annexé ce
territoire sans un seul coup de fusil
cette intégration comme disent les
russes de la crimée beaucoup prêtent à
vladimir poutine
le souhait d'en faire de même avec le
dombass il se dit que la russie aurait
distribué des passeports pour changer le
rapport de force des nationalités sur le
terrain créer un nouveau fait accompli
qui croire très honnêtement je ne crois
pas qu vladimir poutine a besoin
d'annexer le donne basse je pense même
que le don de base lui plus utile les
partis séparatistes je veux dire lui
beaucoup plus utile au sein de l'ukraine
car dans les accords de minsk s'ils sont
remplis à la lettre les députés de cette
région là qui vont avoir un statut
autonome iront à la rada et pourront
bloquer toute décision qui serait
considérée comme contraire aux intérêts
russes donc moi je dis c'est une région
qui plus utiles et les émirs poutine au
sein de l'ukraine kan est en annexe et
quand ça de la russie même merci tatiana
castres va gens nous arrivons au terme
de cette émission merci l'avoir suivi on
se retrouve dans trois semaines juste
après les fêtes de fin d'année le temps
pour moi donc de vous souhaiter
d'excellentes fêtes en famille cette
émission vous pourrez la retrouver sur
nos sites internet france 24 points
comme et franceinfo.fr très bonnes fêtes
de fin d'année
[Musique]